a couple hits last night against sean
manaya four for eight in the series with
a home run and two runs batted in
correa drills one to left field looking
up canna this balls off the top of the
wall gets back to cannon a hurry and
carlos has to put on the brakes
that ball was rocking it off the bullpen
fence
that they came in there at 96 miles an
hour on our matches from supermow you
may see some compression
my gosh
that is a well done load and then just
dropped the head of the bat on it
and an absolute laser beam off that
bank of america sign hit so hard that it
got back to canna in a hurry
julia the thing with cur or with guriel
is
plumber you know this once he swings he
usually puts his bat on the ball and
puts it in place so often
there you go right back to the mound to
montos
and julie guriel is going to reach on an
infield hit they're going to check on
frankie
but he puts the ball in place so much
that the number of swings he takes
the ball is usually in play more so than
most guys who might draw walks because
they foul pitches off or miss
right on
that right thigh
give him a little bit of dead leg
first pitch swinging is brown knowing
that arcade is filling up the strike
zone and this ball is caught by correa
over the shoulder made it look easy
flips it to mile straw correa had to go
a long way for that ball
it was a great visual to see how he put
himself in position to make this call
you can see miles straw just giving way
and letting carlos go out and do carlos
things see how still his head is it kind
of looked like he was high stepping out
there but the reason for that is he's
getting on the balls of his feet to keep
his head still so he can see the ball
the whole way
he struck out his last five of played
appearances so
yes alvarez is left handed but this guy
can do more damage right now than
alvarez can
blade more than that right field
on the warning track tom
makes the catch big spot that frankie
montos gets out of his trance
olson had a three-run home run last
night
on the ground into right field mariano's
scoring from third base
[Applause]
olson
[Music]
you want to score that one for us aj
well first of all this is a great
baseball play
nice swing by olson
nice base running by lowry nice throw by
tucker nice cut off by correa matt olson
did the right thing except he forgot
that the other guys on the other team
can now run him you know arcadia's going
to try to come after you that was a lot
of first pitch strikes like we've
discussed that's the one i'm like okay
i'm getting a fastball out over the
plate hopefully up and putting my
a-swing on and see what happens
[Applause]
another run comes home this time it's
jen lowery
going two outs it's now two nothing
athletics
murphy is off the schneid this year
over 15 coming into this about runner on
third that's the way to get your first
one
mistake
breaking ball
middle middle
murphy barrels it up and hits it through
the 5-6 hole
this is the ending the astros got him in
the postseason last year
on a 2-2 pitch throws his bat at the
pitch and fouls it into the crowd
that'd be great to see on replay if he
actually had his hands on it when the
ball made contact with the bat i'm not
sure if he did or not
i mean i've heard a throw in the barrel
but this is extreme that was awesome
that's the ball skills even when the
bat's not in your hand right
that's incredible
this is way up and it is off the windows
and
gone
breaking some glass four and nothing a's
in the fifth inning
wow
hanging slider this is what you're
supposed to do with them aaron
mariano gets it
[Music]
for a base hit tom is in canna is
chugging home chad lowry pushes two
across
and the a's extend the lead at six
nothing in the seventh
guy struggling with his control base is
loading know he's got to come right
after you get jed lowry gets a little
bit of a cutter up
gets in on him he gets just enough of it
to muscle it into center field for a
two rbi single and push the a's lead to
six to nothing
i imagine this could be the final batter
from lowell tops as he
throws his 100th pitch of the day tucker
drives one deep to right field kyle
tuckers and a solo home run
tucker with rbis in eight of the astros
nine games this year
makes it a six to one game with his team
leading fourth home run of the season
slider that came right back into the
swing path that kyle tucker and he did
not miss it for anything 108.4 off the
back
376-foot line drive to get things going
for the astros hopefully this is what
ignites them
they've been good against bullpens this
season here's jose altuve well the a's
have scored five of their six runs with
two outs the astros could use a little
two out rbi here altuve drives one to
center field sending l'oreal back that
ball is down for a hit straw will score
out two bay in the second base rbi
double for jose altuve it's a six to two
game did a phenomenal job of staying
back on this slider that was great
recognition
and great ability to trust his hands to
wait just a little bit longer to stay on
that
barrel it up and break it into
left-center field
great piece of hitting randley was the
last batter of the evening last night
lined out to center field to end the
game after the astros scored a run on
beekman this time he hits one to right
center field that ball will be down for
a base hit all the way to the wall
altuve will score bradley thinking about
three he's gonna go for it michael
bradley slides into third safe it's a
6-3 game
good job by uncle mike anticipating
fastball
seeing fastball
not missing the fastball
gets those arms extended barrels it up
and he's thinking extra bases right out
of the chute
once it gets past tom out there in right
field he says i'm going to go ahead and
push the envelope and try and get that
extra base and he did
what a blast by brown
[Applause]
here's your defense for it erin 96
get on top of and hit in the upper deck
behind in the count 1-0
seth brown cheating for a fastball he
got it he did not miss it
congratulations on your first major
league home run
astros down to their final out
[Applause]
[Music]
outside corner ball game over the a's
win it and for the first time this year
oakland has a win streak and aj they've
won three out of their last four all of
a sudden